[Music]
Mexicans are murderers and rapists black
kids are super predators gun owners are
monsters and witches Jews are rats
dehumanization is nothing new it's been
around forever and it's come from all
sides and yet it remains the single
greatest threat to America's social
fabric now I know some of you may be
thinking why is Noah the right messenger
for this and I've heard it all over the
last few weeks Noah you're white Noah
you're a man Noah you're straight just
go back to the golf course but that's
actually exactly why I'm here because I
believe that beginning to de-escalate
the risk from dehumanization starts with
a little bit of personal responsibility
so I'd like to share an idea with you
today and it's an idea that some of you
might disagree with but I hope you know
it comes from a place of wanting to
preserve this incredible 250 year-old
experiment with democracy that is the
United States of America it goes like
this perhaps that in beginning to repair
our social fabric from the bottom up
perhaps instead of leaning in to all of
the things that make us different all
the things that dross apart instead of
trying to take back all of the negative
stereotypes that exist about each and
every one of our identity groups just
maybe it's time to reimburse that old
idea of the great American melting pot
not to destroy identity but to build a
shared identity that is greater than the
sum of its parts
and I believe that the way to do that is
to engage with people on their values
and ideas on their merits now why do I
think this is an idea worth spreading
why is this a problem that urgently
needs addressing I actually don't think
you have to look too far to see it in
our last election we had one candidate
demonize an entire country we had
another candidate call half of the
voters of this country deplorable
tragedies like 9/11 brought an
incredible generation of Americans who
gave up established careers to stand
shoulder to shoulder in fighting for our
freedom in our flag today tragedies seem
to produce arguments about who or what
we should ban from this country but it's
not just politics the private sector
plays a role in this to think about the
different ways that you're asked to
define yourself more narrowly on
Facebook you have to summarize your
activities and interests on a page and
linked in all of your work and
accomplishments and a profile one
picture a one-line biography to help
people decide if they want to date you
the media is complicit in this too it's
gotten to the point where all that's
covered seems to be complete and utter
outrage or strict adherence to political
correctness and political correctness
comes from both sides the right is just
as politically correct at about things
like standing for the national anthem as
the left is about things like abortion
or immigration the result is the
creation of almost a pseudo religion
around certain ideas or groups so that
we can't even have serious conversations
about the social issues that matter most
to this country we know how this ends
we've seen it time and time again create
the other ostracize it vilify it and
destroy it it's happening in Myanmar
today it happened in Rwanda in the 1990s
and yes it happened in Europe in the 40s
we cannot stand to see America's social
fabric unravel now I'm not talking about
just top-down institution building I'm
talking about the things that we can
each do to stitch it back together from
the bottom up and that comes back to
this idea of engaging people on their
values and ideas on their merits so what
does that meant for me well it's meant
that I've tried to immerse myself in in
ideas and places that I wouldn't usually
go adding places on the left like the
Huffington Post
BuzzFeed places on the right like
Breitbart Drudge Report even as far
right as The Daily stormer from these
experiences and from conversations with
people in this room and those far beyond
I believe that there is a way to stitch
this fabric back together so let's start
by talking about what it means to engage
people on their values some of you may
know of a senator from Ohio by the name
of Rob Portman senator Portman is a
Republican he was historically quite
conservative and notoriously against gay
marriage he was being vetted as Mitt
Romney's potential running mate in 2012
around that time senator portman son
came out to him as gay now like any good
senator he waited for a politically
astute moment but eventually
eventually he came out and spoke very
powerfully on this issue he changed his
position and said I am doing so not as a
politician not as a conservative but as
a dad who loves his son a lot and wants
him to have the same opportunities that
his sister might have the values of
equality of opportunity the values of a
dad who loves his son a lot a parent who
loves their son a lot should resonate
with all of us if I'm to criticize
credibly I have to acknowledge
appropriately when I see the values that
I care for being embodied by our leaders
which brings me to the second part of
this solution what does it mean to
engage ideas on their merits and to that
I'm going to offer you all three
challenges to it the first put down the
pitchforks step back from the politics
of blame this is much easier said than
done I fall victim to this all the time
it it is so easy to vilify it is so easy
to express anger but the reality is it
doesn't work
it pushes people's backs against the
wall it makes them feel like they're
defending the closely-held identities
and beliefs it actually produces the
cycle of radicalization which leads me
to my second challenge for go labels see
if you can go a week without using words
that end in I st or I am those isint
isms they're easy to throw out how many
times you heard the conversation that's
racist no no I'm not racist or that
sexist no no no I'm not sexist it's not
that racist or sexist ideas need to go
without being called out but naming is
far less powerful than explaining it
produces that same
dynamic of radicalization which brings
me to my third and final challenge don't
be afraid of ideas if I can accept when
I'm in a classroom or I'm at work that I
am learning when I am challenged when I
am pushed beyond my comfort zone
why do I not feel the same way about my
political ideology what does this look
like well I'm hoping you all might model
that with me today some of the ideas
that I've shared came from things I've
read deep on the far left from the
radical Saul Alinsky or all the way here
on the right from provocateurs like Milo
you Napoles if I told you all that when
you walked into the room some of you
might have walked out but the idea is
that the people are far less important
than the ideas so if you agreed with
what I had to say or you liked it great
let's talk about it if you hated it or
you're angry at me right now
great let's talk about it but either way
we got to talk about it because I
believe that the single most important
thing that this generation can do is
keep this great multicultural democratic
experiment going thank you
[Applause]
[Music]